tener hiperplasia prostática benigna
significa que la glándula prostática
está agrandada la próstata es una
glándula del tamaño de una nuez en los
hombres
ubicada debajo de la vejiga la próstata
rodea la uretra que es el tubo por el
que sale en la orina y el semen de su
cuerpo
las vesículas seminales y la próstata
producen un líquido que junto con los
espermatozoides crean el semen
durante la micción normal la orina fluye
de la vejiga por la parte de la uretra
que está dentro de la próstata luego
pasa por el resto de la uretra hasta
salir del cuerpo
por motivos desconocidos la próstata
puede agrandarse con los años
si tiene hiperplasia prostática benigna
su próstata puede agrandarse lo
suficiente como para comprimir la parte
de la uretra que la atraviesa
esto puede hacer que el flujo de la
orina durante la micción sea más lento
sin tratamiento la próstata puede
agrandarse más y reducir el flujo de
orina aún más esto puede impedirle
vaciar completamente la vejiga
consulte a su médico de inmediato si no
puede orinar
su riesgo de tener hiperplasia
prostática benigna es mayor si tiene 40
años o más tiene antecedentes familiares
de hiperplasia prostática benigna tiene
otros problemas de salud como obesidad
cardiopatías vasculapatías o diabetes
tipo 2 no hace ejercicio tiene
disfunción eréctil
los síntomas de la hiperplasia
prostática benigna incluyen micción
frecuente o necesidad de orinar
especialmente de noche
chorro de orina débil o interrumpido
esfuerzo para orinar con el tiempo la
hiperplasia prostática benigna puede
causar las siguientes complicaciones la
incapacidad de orinar
daño a la vejiga y los riñones
infecciones en el aparato urinario
cálculos en la vejiga
y sangre en la orina
si tiene hiperplasia prostática benigna
con síntomas leves o sin síntomas su
médico le puede recomendar una espera
con observación lo que incluye hacerse
revisar la próstata todos los años para
asegurarse de que no empeoren los
síntomas o su salud si tienes síntomas
moderados molestos su médico puede
recomendarle medicamentos como Alfa
bloqueantes o los que se usan para
tratar la disfunción eréctil llamados
inhibidores de la pd E5 ambos
medicamentos relajan el tejido muscular
de la vejiga la uretra y la próstata
esto puede ayudarle a mejorar el flujo
de orina también pueden recetarse
inhibidores de las 5 alfa reductasa
estos ayudan a mejorar el flujo de la
orina Después de varios meses mediante
la reducción de la próstata
puede recibir una combinación de estos
fármacos
si la medicación no alivia sus síntomas
su médico puede recomendarle una
intervención quirúrgica llamada
recepción transuretral de la próstata o
rtv
Durante este procedimiento su cirujano
le inserta por la uretra un instrumento
llamado receptoscopio para llegar a la
próstata
luego se usa un lazo de alambre en el
extremo del receptoscopio para retirar
tejido lo que amplía la uretra
otros procedimientos menos invasivos
emplean láser microondas ondas
radioeléctricas o energía eléctrica
mediante instrumentos insertados con el
cistoscopio que retiran una parte o la
totalidad de la próstata
si su próstata es muy grande su médico
puede recomendar una prostactectomía
abierta
en la próstatectomía abierta su cirujano
hace una incisión en la parte baja del
abdomen una vez que queda expuesta la
próstata el cirujano hace una incisión
en su cápsula externa
a continuación se retira el tejido del
interior de la próstata y se cierra la
incisión de la cápsula con sus duras
por último se cierra la incisión en la
piel con suturas o grapas
la hiperplasia prostática benigna no se
puede prevenir Pero hay cambios de
estilo de vida que pueden hacer que los
síntomas sean más leves evite los
medicamentos que dificultan la micción
tales como los antihistamínicos y los
descongestivos deje de beber líquido
unas horas antes de irse a dormir
evite beber alcohol u otros líquidos que
contengan cafeína
intente Vaciar la vejiga haciendo una
micción doble para hacerlo orine
Espere un momento e intente orinar de
nuevo
para más información sobre la
hiperplasia prostática benigna consulte
a su médico